- [Voiceover] What are all the solutions
to the equation above?
So we have four x squared is equal to 52.
Well, if we wanna solve for x,
we can just divide both sides by four.
And then we get, x squared is equal
to 52 divided by four, is 13.
So x could be equal to,
if x squared is equal to 13,
that means x could be the
positive or the negative
square root of 13.
So x is going to be equal to the positive
or negative square root of 13.
And you could check your answer.
Take positive 13, if you, if you take,
or take positive square root of 13,
well, if you square it,
you're gonna get 13,
and then multiply it times four,
you're gonna get 52.
Take the negative square root of 13,
well, when you square it,
you're going to get 13,
'cause a negative times
a negative is positive.
And then you multiply it times four,
and you're gonna get 52.
So x could be negative
square root of 13, and, or
or, x could be, x could be,
or the two solutions are
x is the negative square root of 13
and x is equal to the
positive square root of 13.
So that's our choice,
right over there.